fopo it stands for the fear of other
people's opinions I remember back before
iPhones we used to have answering
machines so I went home and I pressed
play on the answer machine and I heard
my own voice and I was like what the
heck is that what I actually sound like
what's worse is now you think about
video you play the video back you're
like is that what I actually look like
dear God somebody help you have to
actually overcome all of those excuses
really stop making excuses and say I'm
just gonna start getting results and
then when you play back that video you
have to hear your own voice and you're
probably not gonna like it and so
ultimately these are all mindset courage
things that hold us back